un discurso que sella la recta final de
su mandato el presidente iván duque
instaló el nuevo congreso en el marco de
la celebración del día de la
independencia de colombia el mandatario
saliente entregó un balance de su
gestión propusimos transformar
positivamente a colombia y prepararla
para los retos del futuro sobre las
bases de la legalidad el emprendimiento
y la equidad hemos cumplido
duke centró su discurso en defender el
manejo de la pandemia y de la crisis
migratoria y destacó entre los que
consideran sus logros la aplicación de
la política de paz con legalidad y la
contención del crimen organizado lo que
le valió varias interrupciones por los
abucheos de los congresistas opositores
que lo tildaron de mentiroso alzando
carteles con imágenes de varios líderes
sociales asesinados
para ser el próximo presidente gustavo
petro quien asume el cargo el próximo 7
de agosto contará con la mayoría en el
nuevo congreso el izquierdista tendrá el
apoyo de al menos 63 de los 108
senadores y de 109 de los 186
representantes a la cámara
además prevalecerán las caras nuevas
representando casi dos tercios del
congreso tendrá mayor participación de
mujeres un 29 por ciento con respecto al
20 por ciento de la anterior y ahora un
número récord de representantes de la
comunidad el eje bético más
los nuevos congresistas permanecerán en
su cargo por los próximos cuatro años